and the world of what is is every single
King conqueror or amazing guy in human
history has always had multiple women
that's just the truth of the matter but
it's not a monarchy anymore no it's not
a monarchy anymore but we're still human
beings and we still come from that
Evolution but no then a lot of women and
there are a lot of women regardless if
you want to believe this or not that
would rather be the king's mistress than
the peasant's wife and that's different
like I said if you want if you want that
if you're all in for that go for it you
know like that's not but as a disclaimer
that's I believe that men should
powerful men should stay faithful but
the truth of the matter is that's not
how it always is and there and I think
the conversation came from average women
thinking that they wanted to be with
millionaires average women thinking they
wanted to be with the men of certain
status and it kind of comes with like
the Kevin Samuels thing where he's
talking about high value men and men
making over a hundred thousand dollars
or men making absorbitant amount of
money there are women that have been
programmed to think that they're going
to find a millionaire man that's going
to be able to spend all the time with
them they want that's going to just
cater to their every need that's not
going to lead their they want a man to
be able to go lead a company but not
lead their own relationship and then
he's going to be completely exclusive to
them
Kevin Samuels was just giving the fact
that that's not the reality and I was a
professional athlete I've been around
professional track athletes NFL athletes
professional rugby players and from my
experience there tends to be an
understanding these guys are gone for
weeks at a time everybody loves them
things happen but he gives all of his
resources to the woman that he loves to
the child that he loves and he comes
back and sees them and as long as he
isn't doing it as long as he's doing it
respectively as in he's not coming home
smelling like the girl he's not bringing
home uh kids uh illegitimate kids he's
not bringing um he's he's not giving
it's not all in the media so she's not
being publicly humiliated they tend to
be okay with that so if you're an
average woman or if you're a woman in
general that wants to be with a man
that's making
a lot a a good amount of money then
expect certain things to come with that
type of man that man ain't gonna be the
same man that a 40 50 000 a year guy is
it's just not the same guy I would just
disagree with you a little bit there
that it's not all dependent upon income
you know I've known both and media
industry is saturated with people who
make a [ __ ] ton of money honestly and
I've seen wealthy guys who you know
behave the way you're describing there's
an understanding in the house it's very
clear what's going on there and
everybody seems to be okay with it and
that's fine a son of my business and
then I've seen wealthy men who make
different decisions because internally
they're looking at their family and
they're saying this is what I want for
my family this is what I want for my
life some may be religious some may you
know answer to someone a lot higher than
themselves when it comes to those issues
of fidelity and whatnot and I see what
you're saying about what is but what I'm
concerned about first of all I want to
change what is yeah I want to change
what is that's number one so I'm
speaking to Men I'm speaking to women
and I don't want that to be the goal I
think what's exhausting to me is instead
of people looking like we are and saying
this is what is let's acknowledge the
reality of what we're seeing let's do
our best to to make it better that's
different from someone saying oh guys
I'm your inspiration this is what you
should do with your life you should aim
to be the kind of guy who can have you
know your girl and then a bunch of side
pieces you should aim to be the kind of
guy where there's a separate set of
rules in your relationship and you can
do whatever you want that's what I'm
kind of looking at as some as a mom who
has a son and saying no I don't I don't
want my son to be listening to that
message now maybe he'll listen to it get
exposed to it and say no thank you but I
hope I'm raising them well enough yeah
we'll say that's not for me the counter
message is men are weak men are the
problem for everything yes yeah but then
what what message do you think majority
of men who are fed up with hearing that
message are going to go towards
one but and that's and that's the thing
too it's it might be a childish fantasy
or a younger man's fantasy because they
don't understand stand that sex is
pretty much boring it's I mean it's a
thing it's good don't get me wrong it's
great fine but it like it's let's put
even if you're doing Tyler can we make
that the clip even if you're doing it
right yeah even if you're doing it with
multiple it's just it becomes sex after
a while so like they fed they fantasize
because like I said men are built to be
that way men are built to want to spread
their seed into as many women as
possible into all over the place so it's
it might be a childish kind of idea but
it's a better one than men are weak and
men are trash and we should kill all men
and hate men and men are the problems of
everything that's wrong too especially
when you look at the fact that men are
almost the solution to everything so if
you're going to give men credit for the
patriarchy you have to give them credit
for the iPhone
and and I think that there's there's a
part where we look at only the negatives
of what if what's happened by from men
and not any of the positives but the
positives mean that we get uh podcasts
and microphones and internet and lights
and I think that there has been a net
positive that men have done for the
planet but we don't get that credit men
have died by the hundreds of millions to
protect women and children in war
throughout all of human 100 so to say
that men hate women and women have just
been dragged Along by men throughout all
of society or throughout all of human
history if you like the short clip you
can catch another one here or you can
catch the full episode right here
[Music]